Ich kann auch gar nicht mehr reden. Ich bin zur Abwechslung mal etwas später. Das ist das, was ich gerade sagen wollte.
Meine Güte!
Ich hab gerade MMO-Kreisel-Cry and Rage quittet, weil mich die Leute so aufgeregt haben. Also nicht unsere Gilden-Leute, sondern
die random Leute. Alter, haben die mich abgefuckt, man.
Das ging nicht.
Da musste ich ausmachen. Okay, ich mach jetzt noch mal Stream an. Moin, bis auch wieder am Start!
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, letzten Stream, wo du warst. Ich hab sogar am Anfang extra gefragt, wo ist denn der Feu da? Wo steckt der denn?
Normalerweise ist er noch immer instant da.
Aber diesmal, ich mein, es sollte wahrscheinlich auch Tage geben, da hast du irgendwas anderes zu tun als Abo-Box-Campen.
Ich war nur verwundert, ja.
Übrigens, chat, wobei, sind erst 14 Leute da. Ich glaube, es hat noch keinen Sinn, wenn ich das jetzt frage.
Ähm, ich heb mir das mal auf.
Ach ja.
Und, hab ich irgendwas Spannendes verpasst?
War irgendwas.
Ich hab die letzten Tage nichts an News verfolgt. Ich hab
hab gar keinen Plan, ehrlich gesagt, ob irgendwas Spannendes auch in der Technikwelt gewesen ist.
Tenko, moin.
Ja, was gibt's hier? Das ist jetzt die Frage, was Neues gibt. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab weder großartig Reddit gebraust, noch Hacker-News gebraust. Ach doch, eins hab ich mitbekommen.
Für alle, die im Container-Umfeld unterwegs sind, sei es jetzt mit Docker, Kubernetes, was auch immer,
Docker-Hub
stellt den,
wie war das jetzt noch mal genau, die kostenlosen
Organizations ein. Also sprich, man kann jetzt keine Images mehr in so eine Sammelgruppe
uploaden.
Und ich glaube aber, sie haben heute schon wieder zurückgerudert. Ich hab's nur am Rande so mitbekommen.
Ähm
Madminister,
das machen wir. Erinnere mich nächsten Stream dran. Ich mach nächstes Stream in Public Repo, weil, ich sag dir auch, warum,
weil da fehlen noch eins, zwei wirklich wichtige Sachen, die man machen sollte,
die ich nicht so gemacht hab, wie man sie eigentlich machen sollte.
Erinnere mich, also erinnere mich dran, ich mach das nächste Stream in Public.
Aber da sind ein paar Sachen noch nicht so schön.
Und das machen wir nächsten Stream, und dann kannst du das auch so benutzen und nicht
so halbherzig, wie ich das letzte Mal gebaut hab. Ja, verstehe ich auch nicht, was da los ist,
warum die sich nach und nach abschaffen. Oder brauchst du die unbedingt jetzt? Ich meine, ich kann die auch.
Äh, Spoiler mal, was noch fehlt, da muss ich mal in mich gehen. Ich weiß nur, dass ich gestern im Hinterkopf behalten hab,
dass, also im Vergleich zu dem anderen Repo, was ich noch vorbereitet hab, einiges fehlt.
Äh, was, was fehlt da noch? Also, Third Manager fehlt auf jeden Fall noch.
Ähm, Secret Management fehlt noch, fehlt noch.
Also, Third Manager und, und External Secrets fehlt auf jeden Fall noch.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die ich, die ich noch einmachen würde.
Der Engine X Ingress selbst konfiguriert fehlt noch.
Und das Monitoring fehlt noch, aber External Secrets und Zertifikats Manager ist das, äh,
Wichtige. Aber was, was fehlt da noch?
Und das Monitoring fehlt noch, aber External Secrets und Zertifikats Manager ist das, äh, Wichtige.
Aber, komm, Jett, weil du's bist, ich uploade das schnell irgendwo.
Ich hoffe, ich bin noch eingeloggt, bis der Stream richtig anfängt.
Da kann ich das hier schnell irgendwo hochladen.
Dü, dü, dü, dü.
Ich mach, ich mach hier einen Repo. Ich mach schnell einen Repo, Leute.
Für den Medminister, das er rumbasseln kann.
Ich mach schnell einen Repo. Guck mal hier, wir gehen mal nach GitHub.
Jaja, ähm...
Wir wechseln den Account auf nicht auf Agile Proggers, sondern auf Fifehead.
Wechseln den account auf nicht auf agile progas sondern auf fife hat ich habe ich ich habe mir ich habe mir eine
organization gemacht wo ich sachen vom stream pushen kann wo ich ein bisschen
Eingeschränktere benutzerrechte haben will wo ich nicht unbedingt meinen persönlichen token kauf zugreifen will so wie organization
Repositories
New repo
Ehm stream oder wie nennen wir es stream
Ebenso
Weil da kann ich das ich lösche das dann sag wenn du es gepullt hast dann lösche ich es wieder
8 repo
Okay, so wo haben wir hier unser repo von gestern cute app
habe ich irgendwas drinne was ich nicht was ich nicht pushen sollte
Glaube nicht oder nicht dass ich irgendwie näher nähe kann er eigentlich kann er eigentlich nichts großartig drin sein hier
renovate
Gut das brauchst du nicht dass du eh keinen zugriff drauf
Ansonsten ist hier glaube ich nix nix spannendes trennen was man nicht was man nicht ablohnen könnte
Okay, da lade ich das jetzt mal hoch für dich jetzt status
Aber passt war eigentlich geht es ja
Jetzt push
Also
So hier medminister sag wenn du es geklont hast dann schmeiß ich wieder weg
Wie findet ihr eigentlich den organizations namen 5 header
Passt ganz gut und jetzt chat was meint ihr
Hier ich habe eine frage an euch meint ihr hat es mittlerweile hinbekommen oder nicht
Also heute morgen sah das rucks haben hier angeklickt heute morgen twitter
Heute morgen sah das
Noch so aus als ich mich versucht habe einzuloggen
Denkt ihr denn es geht mittlerweile
ups
Was ist denn jetzt?
Okay es
Wir machen wir machen mal eine umfrage ich will wissen wie ihr auch zu einschränken hast du geklont
Ich war mal eine umfrage
Geht mein account jetzt
Ja nein
So ich bin mal gespannt gespannt was ihr denkt
Oh, du kennst du
Kann ich löschen ok settings
Elite
Das mache ich jetzt hier nicht ok also chat was meint ihr hat es auch hinbekommen
Ja oder nein nein oder ja
Elite des repository
Wache ich muss ernsthaft zum löschen hier letzten zwei factor identifizierung machen na ok ist auch ganz sinnvoll
Dass es nicht jeder machen also schon ganz gut
Ich muss mal kurz auf dem zweiten bildschirm zwei factor und hin also 86 prozent sagen nein
Kann ich euch sagen
Ihr
liegt
Oder ihr lehr liegt liegt lagt ihr liegt ihr liegt falsch
O2 hat es hinbekommen
Ich hätte selbst nicht für möglich gehalten aber O2 hat es geschafft
O2 hat ziemlich genau vier tage gebraucht
Um meinen account zu fixen so dass ich mich einloggen kann man fragt sich natürlich warum so einfache sachen wie ein
login im account
Beim registrieren nicht einfach geht und vier tage braucht fragt man sich jetzt ja wirklich
Ja wie das eigentlich sein kann
Aber sie haben es geschafft sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft
Ich würde zwar natürlich interessieren was was jetzt was genau war
Jetzt wollen sie es aber jetzt übertreiben sie es jetzt übertreiben sie es aber bei O2
Jetzt jetzt übertreiben sie es aber
dass sie es então übertreiben
Kaum ist da fehler behoben also sprich kaum kann ich vier tage nach registrierung
Mein account normal benutzen was ja vorher nicht ging haben sie mir eine mei geschrieben
Lieber O2 kunde
unsere beste auszeichnung ist ihre zufriedenheit
Wenn sie an ihre erfahrungen bei der nutzung ihres tarif denkens wie wahrscheinlich ist es ist es dass sie auch zu einem freund oder kollegen empfehlen
jetzt übertreibt zwar nicht leute
Ich hab vier tage gebraucht bis überhaupt der login in meinem account funktioniert also wir wollen jetzt ja ich freue mich dass es geht aber
Es ist jetzt nur nicht so weit dass ich euch weiterempfehlen würde
Das da wird es noch ein bisschen mehr machen habe ich habe ich tatsächlich
Ich habe noch eine pn geschrieben
Leute ich habe sogar ich habe sogar ich habe jennifer auf twitter gelobt und sogar
O2 community
Das haben wir doch irgendwo in der history noch drinne
Sekunde wo war mal history
meine güte
Ja ach ich habe sie auf deutsch warum habe ich das hier auf deutsch
O2
Ach moment ich bin im falschen browser
deswegen
O2 community ja hier so ich habe ich habe extra schon gepostet dass es geht
dass das sonst nicht funktioniert hätte
Was ist das da eigentlich
Was ist das hier unten
Wo kommt das her das war gestern noch nicht da
Normalerweise würde ich ja sagen ein search bar virus aber wahrscheinlich ein komisches windows update
Der kommentar klick nee warum
Vollkommen ok
Wo kommt das her ist das innen wie macht man das aus vor allem ok rechts klicken geht nicht links klicken taskbar settings
a search nee moment
Hier halt
Normalerweise habe ich da aber kein search icon und das hat oder oder vielleicht hat sich das windows update ist wieder eingeblendet keine ahnung
Ich meine nicht das kleblatt warum überhaupt eine suchleiste da ist die habe ich normalerweise nicht
Ach ja leute und unter windows 10 habe ich auf einmal eine bing suchleiste auf dem desktop gehabt seit dem letzten update hatte das auch schon
Windows 10 bing search
Bar
Auf dem desktop
Mit nach hier auf einmal auf auf einmal war das da
Also das ist auch so ein ding das das regt mich auf wenn auf einmal solche dinge aufploppen die komplett useless sind und
die ich dann als erstes mal wieder ausschalten muss
Normaler früher hätte ich gedacht irgendein toolbar virus oder so aber nee das ist microsoft shit
Ich habe beides unter windows 11 hatte ich die suchleiste hier unten und unter windows 10 habe ich die suchleiste hier mitten mitten auf dem desktop
Was auch immer microsoft microsoft just just microsoft things
microsoft wieder im clown modus
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher aus welchem grund habe ich das im out noch mal hinzugefügt
Als fasching war jetzt weiß ich es wieder
Keine kann ich das dann kann ich das
Die lieten das brauche ich nicht
Weg damit
Wann neuer job
In
6 7 in sieben arbeitstagen
Also hier am 3 april neuer job
Da oder da aber aber wahrscheinlich da
Wahrscheinlich wann millionär näher millionär ist man ja mit 35 habe ich letztens im video gelernt ich bin 38 jetzt bin ich schon drei jahre millionär
Ich hoffe das kommt jetzt nicht zu überraschend
Stonks
Ich hoffe das kommt jetzt nicht zu überraschend stonks
Ach ja soll ich mal kurz gucken was meine stonks machen einfach
Noch ein bisschen was deprimieren das heute abend was machen
scalable app machen meine stonks ich check mal kurz die stonks
Minus 1700 euro exzellent
Exzellent wer wer nicht ja eigentlich sind es minus 1800
Würde ich mal sagen
Ja jetzt jetzt sind sie übrigens minus 1800 jetzt sind sogar minus 1800 acht
Jetzt wird es mal zeit
Also dieses ja also dieses ja ist minus 1800 acht
Jetzt wird es mal also ein jahreszeitraum so viel es wird eigentlich zeit noch mal ein bisschen was einzukaufen
War ich jetzt
Leute etf stellt habe ich noch was hier offen
Geil ich habe noch 67 euro
Und was ich hier noch noch reinbuttern kann da muss ich erst mal wieder in payment machen pay in
Ich morgen früh
Das geht auch wieder hoch das geht auch wieder hoch gar kein ding ist sie
Früher oder später
Sagen wir ist die lautstärke ein bisschen bisschen kaputt
Lautstärke passt
Kaputt
Windows update hat auch wieder audio geräte und so was umgestellt auch ganz schlimm just
clock
Yep, yep, clock. Danke für den sub
Und bumm da Dingsbums auch. Danke für den sub habe ich gar nicht habe ich gar nicht gesehen vorhin
Ja reinmetall hätte ich mal holen müssen als es losgegangen ist hätte man nicht wissen können hat heckler und koch eigentlich auch eine aktie
erst mal erst mal waffenhersteller kaufen
Okay
Dann nicht als johi dankeschön für den sub
So also lass mal überlegen ach ja es gibt noch was neues was ich euch erzählen kann tatsächlich
Also nicht nur nicht nur das auto es hinbekommen hat was mich wirklich sehr verwundert hat aber
Mein aktueller arbeitgeber bekommt auch was nicht hin und zwar
Die bekommen es nicht hin mir ein zeugnis auszustellen irgendwie ich bin jetzt noch sieben arbeit also sieben sieben werktage dort
Und
Sie sind noch nicht in der lage gewesen mir das zeugnis zu geben sie sagen sie ja das kommt noch das kommt noch wie gesagt ich
hab denen erzählt
Wenn ich das am ersten arbeitstag nicht vorzeigen kann dann darf ich meinen neuen job nicht anfangen
Darf den schon anfangen ein paar tage später dann wenn ich das zeugnis habe oder so aber das ist vorschrift geldwäsche
gesetz und sonstige geschichten ich darf nicht anfangen ohne
Im original mein letztes arbeitzeugnis vorgelegt zu haben und eins kann ich euch sagen
Die aktuelle firma wo ich arbeite die hat jetzt vier monate fast fast vier monate zeit
Ja doch vier monate ja vier sagen wir aufgerundet vier monate zeit mir ein zeugnis zu schreiben
So
Und die können sich auf eins verlassen
Die fakt so so lange das also ich gehe da ich gehe da nächste woche noch mal rauf
Über nächste woche gehe ich da noch mal rauf und im zweifelsfall nehme ich den kram auch direkt mit
Ich brauche ja auch noch die bescheinigung für die urlaubstage und so was aber eins sage ich euch leute
Ihr könnt euch auf sehr viel videocontent freuen wenn ich dieses zeugnis nicht bekomme
Weil dann werde ich die auf schadensersatz verklagen
Da können da können die gift draufnehmen
Für jeden tag den ich meinen neuen job nicht antreten kann weil die ihre pflicht nicht erfüllt haben mir das zeugnis auszustellen
das zeugnis auszustellen welche die verklagen
Das ist erst einmal in meinem leben dass ich einen verklage
Aber mehr das bringt ja nix sie sind ja noch nicht im verzug weil ich an euch fertig bin
Bescheid gesagt habe ich mit zeugen oft genug
Aber dann sehe ich es nicht mehr allem und wenn es und wenn es am ende nur 250 euro sind oder so die einem der an schaden
Erstanden sind entstanden sind durch irgendwie die zeit wo man nicht anfangen konnte das sehe ich nicht ein
Kann ich meine rechtsschutzversicherung wenn ich was benutzen
Die leute ohne scheiß ich hoffe nicht dass es soweit kommt ne und
Und es kommt auch doof
Es ist es ist auch doof beim neuen arbeitgeber wenn ich nicht
Was ich am ersten tag anfangen kann weil ich kein zeugnis am start habe
Ne ich glaube ich glaube zu viel ich glaube zu viel
Ich glaube zu viel weil ich weiß es nicht ich glaube ich glaube 500 euro oder so kann es kann es sein ist das so ein beliebter betrag
Weiß ich weiß ich weiß ich nicht
Warum kannst du ohne zeugnis nicht anfangen ich kann ohne zeugnis nicht anfangen weil es vorschrift ist
Unter anderem wegen insider handel geldwäsche und sonst was wenn man anfängt das letzte arbeit
Nein nein nein nicht das letzte das arbeit zeugnis vom letzten arbeitgeber
Bevor man anfängt im original vorzuzeigen fragt mich nicht warum das so ist aber das ist so
Ich habe da mehrfach angerufen es war noch leute dabei das sollte reichen mal ganz davon abgesehen ich muss das ja nicht schriftlich haben
Der arbeitgeber ist verpflichtet mir pünktlich zum ausscheiden ein zeugnis auszustellen
Also ich muss es denen doch nicht mal sagen die sind verpflichtet dazu das zu machen
Ich bekomme das nicht digital ich kriege das auf auf dem zettel queer gleich für den sub
Er hat es verloren können die nicht das das können die nicht sagen dann müssten sie es ja da müssten sie ja vorzeigen können
Meinst du schreiben sie dann schnell und datieren zurück oder wie naja also ich meine irgendwie postausgang bei uns
Nee nee nee ich glaube nicht dass sie da rauskommen
Na das ist ja nicht wild das ist ja nicht wild du kannst es ja vorzeigen auch wenn es falsch ausgestellt wurde
Es geht nur darum man muss das vorzeigen wenn du es nicht vorzeigen kannst kannst du so lange nicht anfangen
Ohne scheiß dann bleibe ich auch im monat daheim und lasse es mir bezahlen von denen wenn die nicht hinterher kommen mit ihrem zeugnis
Kein ding sitze ich mir auch im monat daheim hin und drehe daumchen voll bezahlt zum gehalt vom neuen job wohlgemerkt
Ja das ist das ist chat jetzt muss ich euch mal eine lebensweisheit mitteilen an der stelle
Ich weiß übrigens dass das schreiker nicht so meint ja also das nur weil ich es lese nur weil ihr etwas nicht für möglich haltet
Beziehungsweise etwas noch nicht erlebt habt heißt es nicht dass es so sein kann dass es nicht doch so sein kann
Also ich glaube zum beispiel auch dass wir nicht auf einer flachen erde leben obwohl die von hier ziemlich flach aussieht
Mag jetzt manche überraschen ja aber auch wenn ich einige wenn ich manche sachen nicht selbst gesehen habe können die trotzdem so sein
Wie gesagt ich weiß du weißt das nicht so es ist normalerweise auch nicht so alles eine frage der perspektive genau
Perspektive ist das flat earther argument schlechthin perspektive alles alles ist perspektive und halt immer nur so wie es bei ihnen in die logik reinpasst
Ob das logik zu nennen ist schon wie sie wie sie fragwürdig normalerweise braucht man das auch nicht wenn du aber bei einer bank oder bei einer versicherung anfängst
Vor allem wenn du bei einer bei irgendeinem finanzunternehmen anfängst was gesetzliche vorgaben hat was die überprüfung ihrer mitarbeiter und und und sachen angeht gibt bestimmte auflagen
Dann ist das so ich brauche ein führungszeugnis vor der polizei das habe ich schon habe ich auch schon hingeschickt und ich brauche das letzte arbeitszeugnis
Die erde kann ja gar nicht flach sein wir sollen die reptiloiden die sind komplett unter uns das weiß man doch kennst du nicht obamas exenmensch bodyguard
Ich dachte das ist allgemein bekannt warum warum wisst ihr das nicht
Also das hätte ich jetzt erwartet dass man 2023 zumindest schon mal was von obamas exenmensch bodyguard gehört hat
Ihr habt einfach keine ahnung mal selbst informieren leute kommt dann immer als antwort informiert euch doch selbst und unabhängig dann wisst ihr sowas auch
Im prinzip erzählen die auch immer dann gleich kämpeln
Letztens auch wieder schon chemtrails überm haus gehabt
Attacke wieder
Nun gut genug verschwörungstheorie jibait
Haben wir irgendein video was mich anspricht lass mal gucken ich refresche was verdient eine lehrerin
Leute mich interessiert vielleicht was eine lehrerin verdient aber ich würde im leben im traum egal wie viele mir bezahlen würden
Niemals lehrer werden ich glaube es gibt
Ne mal lehrer es gibt glaube ich kaum noch was beschissenes was ich mir vorstellen könnte ich mein first level support ist vielleicht ähnlich beschissen
Aber lehrer ist noch beschissener also lehrer zu sein ist wirklich
Das ist mit das
Bescheuertes und beschissene was ich mir persönlich für mich vorstellen könnte ich weiß nicht was was was da was der cute chat zibaro was den da reitet lehrer werden zu wollen
Ist mir unbegreiflich
Der cute mod
Aber gut jeder wie er will ja
Sag mal max habt ihr eure lehrerin auch so begrüßt wie im video weiß ich hab das video nicht angeguckt ich werd das jetzt auch nicht angucken
Ne ne ne ich will nein nein nein das will ich jetzt nicht gucken
Lass mal gucken gibt's irgendwas gibt's irgendwas was mich hier anspricht von
AI on the edge
Ja das hab ich ausprobiert das funktioniert bei meinem strommesser nicht richtig
Das ist ein cooles projekt aber es hat nicht richtig funktioniert
Wahrscheinlich auch weil der abstand abstand zu gering ist die idee ist cool
Aber es hat bei mir nicht richtig funktioniert
Fireship aber Fireship hat nix ach das ist irgendwelche image
Bearbeitungs Stellungs AI das juckt mich nicht es sind generell allgemein wissen
Okay diese thumbnail ist sicherlich komplett zufällig rein rein zufällig entstanden und dann youtube hat das dann dahin das nicht absicht
Fireship ist gut aber auch das ganze AI Zeug ich muss euch mal ganz ehrlich sagen mich langweilen
Wie geht's euch eigentlich bei diesen ganzen AI Videos
Ich muss sagen mich langweilen die AI Videos seit der ersten Woche schon
Es ist im Prinzip immer das gleiche so JETGPT macht mir eine Webseite die 10 coolsten AI Tools
Und alle machen quasi die gleichen 15 Dinger
Ich hab mich nach einer Woche schon gelangweilt
Und es ist nicht so als würde ich sagen ich finde JETGPT unsinnig oder sowas in der Richtung
Ich finde die Entwicklung beeindruckend zu sehen über die letzten Jahre
Da hat sich ja enorm viel getan aber trotzdem was da teilweise erzählt wird
So nach dem Motto ist das schon echte Intelligenz und ich weiß nicht
Also wer mit JETGPT schon mal irgendwelche Technik Sachen sich angeguckt hat wird nach ein paar Zeilen schon feststellen
Okay das ist einfach vieles zusammen gelogen
Ja die fantasieren sich da immer irgendwas zusammen
Also das ist schon eine coole Technik und ich gehe auch davon aus dass das eine Vielzahl neuer Anwendungsmöglichkeiten eröffnet
Ohne aber in bestehenden Anwendungen ein bisschen ergänzt wird
Es wird auf jeden Fall Impact haben
Jetzt sind wir ja quasi kurz bevor die Aliens landen ist es halt nicht
Schwer in Worte zu fassen was ich da genau drüber denke
Also wie gesagt nach der ersten Woche haben die mich schon gelangweilt
Es war auch immer gleiche Kram
Letztens habe ich irgendwie in einer Talkshow so einen Ausschnitt gesehen
Da meinte eine JETGPT hätte schon quasi auf
Also wenn man JETGPT gesagt hat irgendwie sie sollen wissenschaftliche Arbeit zum Thema XY schreiben
Da meinte sie irgendwie das wäre nicht auf Genie Niveau
Wo ich mir dann so gedacht habe ey ich muss JETGPT drei Technik Sachen fragen und ich sehe sofort dass das Ding Mist ausspuckt
Also das ist voll Genie Niveau die Ansprüche habe ich gar nicht da dran
Es wäre schon gescheit wenn es mir einfach erklären könnte
Bei einem Kommando Zeilen Befehl die Parameter ordentlich und nicht irgendwelche Sachen hinzu erfinden
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass JETGPT immer besser wird
Ich meine jetzt haben wir aber JETGPT 4 am Start was jetzt der Nachfolger von 3.5 ist
Das was hinter JETGPT steckt das wird auf jeden Fall besser werden und es wird auch immer mehr verschiedene Sachen kombinieren können
Dass du dann Bilder, Audio, Text und sowas zusammen das wird schon alles hinhauen
Und es wird auch immer näher dran sein an Sachen die man zu 90-95% irgendwann mal vielleicht auch verwenden kann
Also in Anwendungsfällen wo man sich auch ein bisschen drauf verlassen muss
Aber wenn es um wichtige Sachen geht sehe ich da JETGPT erstmal nicht
Na ja YouTube wird da noch ein bisschen drauf abgehen auf dieses Thema und mal gucken was dann sonst so kommt
So kein Video dabei was mich irgendwie groß anspricht
Erstmal ein Thumbnail machen und irgendwie geschockt gucken oder überrascht gucken
Irgendwie nix dabei in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
Leute dann erzähle ich euch einfach noch ein bisschen was wenn es keine gescheiten Videos gibt
Ich weiß bloß nicht was
Ich hab mir ganz spontan nach meinem MMO-Ragequit heute den Stream angeschmissen
Ich kann euch eigentlich gar nicht
Lass mal überlegen gibt es irgendwas
Okay ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen
Sekunde ich hab hier vom letzten Stream bestimmt noch mein Notizzettel da schreibe ich manchmal Dinge auf die ich noch sagen will
Vielleicht steht da hier irgendwas drinne
Mehr Copanades stellt
Nee mehr Copanades stellt das kann man nicht machen
Kennst du den Muffin man? Ich kenne den Typ aus Schreck ja
Aber was meinst du wahrscheinlich nicht
Protonmail
Jetzt irgendwas wo ich
Ich brauch jetzt fast 45 Minuten für den Stream und nicht irgendwas umfangreiches
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, wahrscheinlich erzähle ich euch jetzt schon was was alle seit 15 Jahren wissen
Wusstet ihr eigentlich dass man bei Google Mail aus einer E-Mail Adresse mehrere machen kann
Indem man die E-Mail Adresse mit einem Plus davor zusammenhängt
Also wenn ihr jetzt beispielsweise sowas habt wie cackle at gmail.com
Dann könnt ihr daraus sowas machen wie lulw plus cackle at gmail.com
Und dann könnt ihr euch mit dieser E-Mail Adresse registrieren aber es kommt trotzdem bei cackle at gmail.com an
Also wusste ich auch nicht so kann man quasi sich nahezu und endlich viele E-Mails erstellen
Wenn denn, wenn denn und das bin ich mir sicher machen schon einige Seiten
Ich hab es bis jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert auf vielen Seiten aber ich bin mir sicher machen einige Seiten
Dass plus bei gmail nicht rausfiltert vielleicht machen das manche Seiten schon
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man dann sagen dann benutze ich es halt nicht
Wie viele E-Mails hast du du meinst E-Mail Accounts
E-Mail Accounts selber also E-Mail Postfecher hab ich nicht so viel
Ich hab einfach Redirects
Ich hab bei Cloudflare glaube aktuell 7 verschiedene Domains
Und 1,2 Domains also eigentlich sind es nicht 1,2, es sind 2 Domains
Benutze ich für E-Mail Weiterleitung um mich zu registrieren
Ich hab zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie
Gut die Domain erzähle ich euch jetzt nicht
Ich hab dann zum Beispiel sowas wie github1
Ja und dann add www.domain.com
Oder github2 oder github3 oder was auch immer
Sowas hab ich das sind alles E-Mail Weiterleitung an ein anderes E-Mail Postfach
Aber sobald man sich eine Domain registriert hat kann man das ja so machen
Man braucht ja nicht wirklich für jede Mail ein Postfach
Man kann ja auch die Mail einfach sammeln und dann an ein Postfach weiterleiten
Was sogar die deutlich sinnvollere Variante ist, sonst blickst du dir irgendwann mit Zugangsdaten nicht mehr durch
Das Video zu Gmail hab ich auf der Startseite wirklich?
Wo?
Ach
Dann auch ein Video, das wusste ich nicht
Also ohne Mist ich guck seine Videos
Also ist das nicht, das hab ich nicht geguckt
Ich wusste nicht, dass er auch ein Video zugemacht hat
Das war jetzt noch nicht mal
Ich erzähl jetzt was, weil ich vor 2 Tagen
Das hab ich heute
Heute hab ich das erst wieder in irgendeinem Blogpost gelesen
Aber nicht in dem Video
Deswegen dachte ich mir ich muss euch das mal erzählen
Weil das vielleicht viele nicht wissen
Aber ja
Ist so
Ich benutze es aber selten
Wie gesagt, ich benutze meine eigenen Domains mit E-Mail-Weiterleitung
Bin ich immer noch am besten
Dann könnt ihr nämlich auch schlicht und ergreifend nichts filtern
Das heißt dann
Blablablub
At meine Domain.com
Wisst ihr was doof ist, was wirklich kacke ist
Dass Cloudflare keine.de Domains hat
Beziehungsweise verwalten kann
Sonst hätte ich einfach
Alle Domains
Bei Cloudflare
Hast du den Datenlag von Deezer mitbekommen
Ist Deezer nicht der Napster Nachfolger
Das ist doch irgendein Musik...
Nee, nee, Quatsch, Quatsch
Deezer ist von der Telekom
Das ist der Musikservice
Oder was war das nochmal
Irgendein Musikstreaming Service
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen
Leak, suchen wir doch mal danach
Datenlied, das war ja schon im Februar
Ey, hab ich nicht mitbekommen
Völlig nicht
Sicher, dass Cloudflare keine.de Domains kann
Ja, sicher
Leider, leider kann das Cloudflare nicht
Cloudflare
tld.de
Ah
Ja, sicher
Leider, leider kann das Cloudflare nicht
Cloudflare
Ah
Hello, I am unable to change my name server
Blablabla
Die können keine.de Domains
Cloudflare
Ich weiß nicht warum
Oder können sie das mittlerweile
Ne, oder?
Also
Ich meine nicht zwangsläufig DNS
Sondern
DNS kann ja durchaus sein, dass sie das machen
Aber du kannst keine
Du kannst keine Domains
registrieren und Domains verwalten
bei Cloudflare mit.de
DNS warum nicht
Aber das geht nicht, also du kannst keine
Cloudflare registrieren
Keine.de Domains registrieren
Was ziemlich kacke ist
Ne, du musst ja nicht zu Strato oder sowas
Bei Strato habe ich
Bei Strato habe ich eine 1 Euro
Vm
Ja, korrekt
Geht nicht
Was zahlst du für deine Domains wenn ich fragen darf?
Ich kann nachgucken
Ich kann meine Vm aufmachen
Auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
Mich bei Cloudflare einloggen
Und bei
Namecheap
Porkbun, ich habe ja
Bescheuerterweise bei relativ vielen
Registrarien
Domains
Ah, ich kann mich nicht
Einloggen, so irgendwie
Zwischen 5 und 7 Euro im Jahr
Kostet der Kram, das ist nicht teuer
Also
Alles, alles in Ordnung, da muss man sich
Nicht viel Gedanken machen heutzutage bei Domains
Domains sind eigentlich
Fast immer sportbillig
Heutzutage, wenn man nicht eine irgendwie
Premium Domain einem
Abkaufen will
Also wenn ich jetzt 0.de
Haben will, die ist wahrscheinlich schon belegt
Was kann ich gegen Fishing machen
Auf keine Links in E-Mails drücken
Oder in Chatnachrichten
Oder solche
Dinger
Ah ja gut, wenn du natürlich wissen willst, wie kann ich das erkennen
Da gibt es ein paar Sachen, also
Es sind ja hauptsächlich E-Mails
Klar, gefischt werden kann man
Potenziell über alles mögliche, auch über
Messenger-Nachrichten, über Twitter-Nachrichten
Über alles mögliche, aber
Sagen wir mal so zu 90% sind es ja schon
E-Mails, heutzutage auch immer noch
Du kannst
Den Link dir angucken
Ob der Link so aussieht, wie du ihn
Erwartest, also du kannst ja über den Link drüber
Haffern und gucken, was da dahinter steckt
In der E-Mail und wenn der Link angeblich
Auf meinebank.de geht, aber
Im Browser, äh nicht im Browser, in
Deinem E-Mail kleint, unten drinnen steht
OmegaLol.China
Als Domain-Target, dann stimmt
Irgendwas nicht
Du kannst auch in die E-Mail-Header gucken, Absenderadresse
Wo kommt das ganze her
Über welche Relays wurde das ganze verschickt
Sieht das irgendwie
Legit aus
Gut gemachte Phishing-Mails sind
Fast nicht
So auf den ersten
Blick zu
Klassifizieren als solche
Deswegen, noch viel besser ist
Wenn du deine
E-Mails, wenn du wirklich einen Anhang
Aufmachen willst, mach das unter der Linux-VM
Okay, Punkt IO
Und Punkt TV
Kostet natürlich ein bisschen was
Übrigens, witzigerweise
Äh, lonely
Ich weiß nicht, ob dir
Ob dir das bekannt ist, wusstest du
Das Punkt TV
Nichts mit Fernseh
In dem Sinn zu tun hat
Und das Punkt IO
Nichts mit Cloud und Input Output zu tun hat
Von den Domains
Sondern, dass das die Top-Level-Domains
Sind
Von irgendwelchen Mini-Insel-Staaten
Ja, genau
Okay, ihr kennt das
Ihr kennt das, alles gut
Ja, IO-Domains sind teuer
Hör mal gucken, was sowas kostet
Wo kann man bei Cloudflare überhaupt
Eine Augen, mann
Haben die keine Public-Suche
Für Domains
Was ist denn das
Lul
Geh mal halt zu
Irgendem explibischen anderen an
So
Guck mal, was so eine IO-Domain kostet
Also
Qtchat.io
Das geht doch
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung
34 Dollar im Jahr
Und danach
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung
Eigentlich sollte man sich fast
Qtchat.io schon registrieren
Oder
Ist ein richtig cooler Domain, aber
Aber ich kann mir nicht noch
Ne Domain registrieren
Ich hab schon zuviel unsinnige Domains
Mir gehört zum Beispiel
kappalul.com
Keine Ahnung, was mich da geritten hat
Geht doch eigentlich der Preis für IO-Domains
Was ist qtchat.tv
Das könnte ne Webcam
Das könnte ne Camgirl-Webseite sein
Oder? Qtchat.tv
Guck mal, kostet ja fast gar nichts
Qtchat.tv
Ich hab fast hinterher geschmissen
Ist Qtchat.tv
Okay
Qtchat.tv
Ist noch nicht vergeben
Kostet auch nur 34 Euro
Wolltest du nicht mal
Qtchat.tv kaufen?
Doch, wollte ich
Telekom bisschen zu trollen
Unavailable
Warum?
Hat die Telekom da vielleicht
Ihre Hände mit im Spiel?
Könnte das sein? Ach ne, die hat schon
Irgendjemand gekauft, oder?
Jaja
Das hat schon irgendjemand gekauft
Wollen wir mal gucken?
O2.Gay?
Okay, das ist
Das ist teuer
.com ist natürlich schon
belegt
Magenta Pro
für 7k
Ey, wer Pro sein will
muss halt auch Pro Money haben
für die Domain
Erinnert euch noch an diese Diamant App?
Irgendso ne App, die irgendwie
die 5.000 Euro gekostet hat
im App-Store und die nix konnte, außer
ich bin reich anzuzeigen?
Und das haben dann Leute gekauft?
Wobei zu diesem thema fand ich immer noch am lustigsten die story
Ich weiß ich habe keine wisse ich habe keine ahnung von fußball aber irgendeinen italienischen
national spieler haben sie mal im auto erwischt mit irgendwie zwei koffern voll geld also wurde
irgendwie auto wurde irgendwie reingeguckt von der polizei und die polizei hat ihn da drin erwischt
mit zwei koffern geld und da meinte die polizei irgendwie zu ihm ja her xy was haben sie denn mit
so viel geld vor oder war seine antwort ich bin reich es hat voll gereicht als antwort
ist wahrscheinlich auch die ehrlichste antwort ihre geben konnte das haben sie mit so viel
geld vor ja ich bin reich soll ich phishing mails löschen wenn ich zu 100 prozent weiß
dass es eine ist wenn du zu 100 prozent weiß dass es eine ist dann war umgekehrt was spricht
entgegen löschen warum willst du den müll aufheben es sei denn du willst sie später mal angucken und
genauer analysieren aber ich würde es löschen ich lösche total oft irgendwelche zwielichtigen
scam mails warum soll ich die mein imap voll müllen lassen ja legit genau aber aber eigentlich
müsste das müsste das schon nach nigeria dann wäre das zumindest ein bisschen in einklang mit
früheren spam mails erfahrung mit forever workstation pro sicherheitskopien des licenskis
nein mit sowas habe ich keine erfahrung und da gibt es hier auch keine links zu
denkst du 52.000 euro ist ein gutes gehalt für ein in house it admin ja und nein das kann man
pauschal nicht sagen kommt auf das aufgabe also es ist jetzt auf jeden fall nicht auf der hohen
seite so viel kann ich denke ich schon mal sagen aber es kommt auf die region an es kommt auf deine
erfahrung an es kommt auf das themengebiet an es kommt auf den einsatzbereich auf das aufgabengebiet
an kann man so pauschal nicht sagen natürlich kommt es auch auf die arbeitszeit an also ohne
informationen kann man da nahezu nichts wirklich stichhaltige sinnvolles zu erzählen es ist auf
jeden fall nicht auf der hohen seite so viel kann man denke ich sagen aber wenn du jetzt zum
beispiel vier tage woche im osten arbeitest ist es denke ich schon mal ganz gut also kann man nicht
sagen da braucht man mehr details zu und region ist wichtig also zum beispiel frankfurter finanz
branche generell gab es ja letztens mal wieder eine statistik drüber dass banken und versicherungen
und so am meisten bezahlen ich glaube gefolgt von der pharmaindustrie und was frankfurter
finanz branche ist nice frankfurt an sich ist allerdings auch teuer und dementsprechend ist
da halt auch das gehaltsniveau noch ein bisschen höher und dank fachkräftemangel in der it reißen
sie sich in frankfurt um die paar verbliebenen it leute an die man noch irgendwie dran kommen kann
aber auch anderweitig in deutschland je nachdem was es halt dort auch kostet mit welchen aufgaben
kann man rechnen wenn man in eine microsoft infrastruktur abteilung kommt ich würde damit
gar nicht rechnen ich würde es gar nicht anfangen microsoft infrastruktur abteilung das ist ja ok
ich bleibe bei dem was ich vorhin gesagt habe ich würde nie lehrer werden nicht da könnten
sie mir egal wie viel bezahlen was sie was ich würde es nicht machen was ich auch nicht machen
würde ist bin aus admin oder in einem microsoft infrastruktur abteilung zu gehen aber noch ein
ticken lieber als lehrer zu werden aber würde ich auch nicht machen aber da könnten sie mich
auch zumindest gehaltstechnisch bestechen dass ich also wenn die sagen würden max du musst
das für uns drei vier jahre machen dann hast du finanziell für den rest deines lebens ausgesorgt
und deine familie und deine kinder und deine enkel und alle dann würde ich das auch ein paar jahre
machen aber da müssten sie mir wirklich schon viel schmerzensgeld bezahlen dass ich winn aus
admin werde ja dann ist es ja keine minifirma aber auch kein riesen konzern ja aber wie gesagt kann
man nicht sagen also wie viele jahre berufserfahrung hast du was sind die was sind die aufgabengebiete
welche welche branche wo welche welche region also 52k ist durchaus in in der normalen gehaltsspanne
ja es ist jetzt allerdings nicht auf der hohen seite und ich denke auch nicht für nordrhein
westfalen aber wenn du jetzt halt vorletztes jahr oder letztes jahr eine ausbildung fertig
gemacht hast könnte das durchaus je nach aufgabenfeld vollkommen in ordnung sein kann
es wenig zu sagen ich versuche gerade in deffops einstieg als jemand der jahre lang nur microsoft
stells gemacht hat selbst da bekommst du einstiegs gelte um die 60 und gesagt ob drauf an was man
macht oder wo man das macht genauso aufgabenfeld wie viel erfahrung man hat kann man alles so
pauschal immer schlecht sagen
habe ich gerad er hat mich jetzt hinter auf ein systemingenieur aber die schreiben noch
ingenieur bei uns sind das alles nur noch engineers und arkitekt mittlerweile stelle
beworben mit schwerpunkt gcp ach so google cloud ich habe gcp 8000 gerade zusammen gelesen
und ich dachte das ist irgendwie so eine irgendwie so eine maschine die am fließband autos zusammen
schraubt oder sowas gcp 8000 oder in storage oder in storage system oder sowas
also ich habe noch nie beauftragte pen tests durchgeführt das nicht
aber geguckt ob man irgendwie von außen an irgendwelche services dran kommt ob es irgendwelche
standardpasswörter sind die benutzen ob irgendwelche ports offen sind ob was weiß ich
irgendwelche default user gehen das habe ich natürlich auch schon gemacht
ja gucken ob es eine veraltete webserver version verwendet mit mit bekannten lücken und gibt
es ein paar so standards angriffsszenarien das habe ich auch schon gemacht aber noch
nie irgendwie jetzt auf auftrag so nach dem motto mache mal einen pen test wüsste ich
auch gar nicht wo ich damit wo ich da gescheit anfangen soll
hast du dir gerade selbst geantwortet oder hat irgendein fife hat chatter was sinnvolles
da drauf geschrieben du hast jetzt fünf jahre ok naja also ich denke da geht das durchaus
in ordnung erst mal es sollte natürlich perspektivisch schon ein bisschen mehr werden als 52k wie
gesagt natürlich kommt es auch immer noch darauf an wie ja wie wie wie umfangreich beziehungsweise
wie kompliziert jetzt so das themengebiet ich meine windows it administration das kann
ja alles sein von du installierst bei irgendwelchen leuten vor ort am schreibtisch den neuen
drucker oder du machst active directory oder du machst irgendwelche anderen windows geschichte
gibt es ja vieles ja wenn es halt was ist was jeder da hergelaufen feldwald und wiesen
praktikant admin machen kann dann kann man am endeffekt nicht so viel erwarten wenn es
was ein bisschen komplizierteres ist und vor allem was gefragt ist dann solltest du perspektivisch
auch auf jeden fall mehr rausholen als da 52k ich würde auch die windows admin machen
aber es gibt ja leute die das gerne gerne machen anscheinend es ist mir auch unbegreiflich
wie man gerne windows admin sein kann aber ich will jetzt einer keinem was einreden
wenn ihr gerne windows admin seid leute das ist schön für euch dann seit windows admin
hier oder fünf tage ich immer vier tage ich werde ich werde nie wieder fünf tage arbeiten
leute nie wieder ich habe keine ahnung leute es ist nicht so als bin ich hier wandeln das
wandeln das job orakel ich kann euch sagen in welcher branche ich tätig bin wie mein
gehalsverlauf war habe ich ja auch jetzt schon in videos ab und zu mal verarbeitet und so
meine generellen gedanken dazu ob jetzt diese eine sache genau dort in nrw ich habe keine
ahnung aber zum einstieg klingt 65k eigentlich erst mal recht gut ja für mich ist es unter
windows immer noch so wenn ich in windows was machen muss wurschtel ich mich durch mit
google bis es dann irgendwie tut ich muss zum glück auf der arbeit prinzipiell kein
windows machen da haben andere leute für und im neuen job zum neuen job auch nicht im neuen
job ist auch nichts mit windows max was magst du an windows administrieren nicht das ist
eine mega umfangreiche frage wo ich erstmal in mich gehen muss also ok gibt ein paar sachen
die ich nicht mache kommandozeilen administration ist unsinnig unter windows komplett unsinnig
zumindest wenn man lilux gewohnt ist ja mittlerweile geht es besser dank powershell und den passenden
cmd lets oder wie der kram heißt ist aber immer noch abartig wenn ich schon sehe dass
man standardmäßig in gui bekommt auf dem server raste ich aus wenn ich sehe dass man
um telnet zu verwenden erstmal windows feature windows feature hinzufügen und aktivieren
klicken muss oder sowas weiß gar nicht hier hier turn windows feature on und off für telnet
da denke ich mir auch immer lieber microsoft sind nicht mehr ganz dicht ich finde eigentlich
so ziemlich alles an windows server scheiße was ist was es nur scheiße zu finden gibt
also windows generell aber windows server auf desktops ist das ja noch irgendwie erträglich
weil man halt windows als als os hat aber man hauptsächlich halt in irgendwelche zeit
in irgendwelchen anwendungen verbringt aber mit windows sich selbst den ganzen tag zu
beschäftigen ne ne ne ne beim besten will nicht also bevor ich windows administrator
werde da würde ich lieber überlegen was würde ich auch da würde ich da würde ich
da würde ich sogar lieber angular frontend sachen mir angucken und da habe ich schon
absolut kein bock drauf aber windows admin ist wirklich das allerletzte was ich mir geben
könnte es kann aber nichts passieren wenn ich nur die email öffne aber kein anhang
das kommt auf dein email programm an wenn das nach html email ist und dein email programm
eingestellt ist auf html emails anzeigen und irgendwie es eine verwundbarkeit in deinem
email programm gibt ist theoretisch schon denkbar dass durch das pure öffnen der email
was passieren kann es ist zwar sehr unwahrscheinlich aber ausgeschlossen ist das nicht deswegen
kann ich dir nur empfehlen wenn du emails öffnen möchtest prinzipiell nicht im html
modus sich die emails anzugucken sondern minimal html oder am besten plaintext und
noch besser das dann auch noch unter linux machen in der vm dann bist du auf der sicheren
seite schon mal angular probiert nee ehrlich gesagt habe ich auch nie angular probiert
weil es ist was wo ich abstand halte von auch auch wenn ich javascript mittlerweile fast
als meine zweit beliebteste sprache klassifizieren würde also javascript hat wirklich einen
steilen aufstieg hingelegt die letzten jahre und ich meine damit nicht die popularität
jetzt irgendwie weltweit sondern bei mir persönlich also hättest du mich hättest du mich vor
zehn jahren hättest du 2013 zu mir gesagt wobei nee ja doch hättest du vor zehn jahren
zu mir gesagt oder hättest du vor 15 jahren zu mir gesagt mach was in javascript hättest
du gesagt alter geh weg so hättest du mich vor zehn jahren gefragt was mach was in javascript
ehrlich gesagt ja ok könnte man sich mal überlegen und sagst du mir jetzt mach was
in javascript ja easy habe ich bock drauf ich will nicht sagen dass ich der krasse javascript
checker bin aber es ist nicht so dass es mir wieder strebt was in javascript zu machen
mittlerweile mache ich javascript tatsächlich ganz gerne da javascript hat wird und wird
es immer haben so komplett wirre sachen so hier ihre sachen mit ihrem triple gleich
oder oder dass irgendwie array empty array irgendwie ungleich empty array ist und solche
komischen dinger ganz wirres zeug aber ganz ehrlich wann hast du da im alltag jetzt tagtäglich
berührungen mit
war mal so eine rangliste von alti jobs bock das ist schwierig alti jobs zu ranken weil
es gibt keine definierte anzahl an alti jobs da müsste man sich halt auf ein paar große
große sachen beschränken so die die einheitlich so genannt werden oder mehr oder weniger einheitlich
weil es nennt den krempel mittlerweile jeder anders bei manchen ist es bei den bei bei
so old school deutschen unternehmen ist es da noch ein ingenieur bei den meisten ist
es ein engineer dann gibt es die leute die noch system oder server administrator schreiben
manche schreiben defops engineer manche schreiben def sec ops und dann fehlt da noch nee dann
fehlen noch def bis sec defops und was kommt als nächstes finn def bis win sec ops oder
was auch immer es wird ja immer länger first level windows support ja ok das würde ich
auch nicht machen ist es safer mails im browser zu nutzen oder emailprogramm macht es überhaupt
ein unterschied ja das macht man das macht ein unterschied also das anfällige ist ja
immer das rendern der inhalt ist im browser so und ist bei emailprogramm natürlich nicht
anders also wenn die email angezeigt wird in was anderem als plaintext natürlich potenziell
kann es auch bei einem öffnen und beim anzeigen plaintext was passieren aber realistisch
soll ich realistisch ist es nicht aber gut kann natürlich kann natürlich vorkommen und
dann ist halt ich frage wie rendert das emailprogramm den html emails mozilla wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwie was also thunderbird wird wahrscheinlich was mozilla mäßiges verwenden und das ios
mail wird wahrscheinlich wie alles andere safari benutzen vermute ich jetzt weiß ich
nicht keine ahnung wo ich es mal vermuten und insofern kann man denke ich schon sagen
wenn man es im browser ausführt ist es aus einem gesichtspunkt sicherer man hat höchst
wahrscheinlich einen aktuellen browser in dem man es öffnet dann ist natürlich die
frage wie ist die web anwendung gemacht von deinem jeweiligen email anbieter du machst
ja nicht einfach email im browser direkt und du brauchst nicht eine web anwendung ähm
wer zu sagen also ich würde sagen ja wahrscheinlich ist es potenziell entticken ist es kann auch
sein dass jetzt irgendein aspect überhaupt nicht bedacht habe aber wenn man html emails
lesen will weil man unbedingt voll gerendert haben will in html könne ich mir vorstellen
ist man in einem aktuellen browser mit jublock und allem zeug drinne wahrscheinlich sogar
noch ein ticken sicherer als über den emailprogramm auf der anderen seite intern werden die email
programme natürlich auch ein browser verwenden wahrscheinlich chrome und bei thunderbird
mozilla firefox aber da weiß man nicht ob der aktuell ist also vielleicht vielleicht
ist man damit ein bisschen sicherer das beste ist aber eh das einfach in einer linux vm
zu machen ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen ich habe letztens wieder ein video gesehen
von einem technische home automation channel den ich öfters mal auf youtube gucke den
kann ich mir nicht so oft angucken weil der ist relativ überdreht immer ne wie heißt
der paul home automation hier hibbert den da von dem habe ich letztens ein video angeguckt
how i got hacked und er ist genau auf die gleiche masche reingefallen die aktuell im
umlauf ist nämlich gefakte emails verschicken die als screensaver getarnt sind und dann
cookies aus dem browser abgreifen pass mal auf ich zeige euch ich zeige euch die stelle
wo es darauf wo es drauf ankommt ja guck pdf pdf getarnt pdf getarnt als screensaver
also ein bisschen das wo sie mich auch versucht haben zu scam ja das ist tatsächlich das
beste ne vm zu verwenden ja und die ursprungs email die er bekommen hat die war auch ich
irgendwo zeigte die ich finde es jetzt findet sich wo die ursprungs email zeigt es ist es
ist tatsächlich relativ ähnlich zu naja egal zu dem scam den sie bei mir probiert haben
und er ist halt drauf auf drauf reingefallen also da sieht man mal es ist eine sehr gute
idee der datei endung ich finde es übrigens auch fragwürdig dass wenn aus das standardmäßig
hat guck mal hier ist es ist immer noch so das sollte ne ne ist nicht so hier hier habe
ich eine änderung hier habe ich eine änderung hier habe ich keine endung warum ok wie plant
man das überhaupt ein früher konnte man hier auf view oder so show file extensions hier
und ja das sollte man auf jeden fall machen
bin ich ehrlich gesagt eh fragwürdig dass es eine default einstellung und wenn unter
windows ist aber das beste ohne scheißleute soll abschließend zu sagen wenn ihr irgendwas
aufmachen wollt wo ihr euch nicht ganz sicher seid oder am besten sogar wenn ihr
emails in html lesen wollt machts in der linux vm dann wird euch zu 99,999 prozent nichts
passieren du findest es befremdlich dass linux keine endung hat linux sind die endung halt
egal und der linux funktioniert das anders als unter windows unter windows ist es so dass
an den datei endung festgemacht wird welche anwendung das öffnen soll und der linux funktioniert
das anders und der linux kriegst du zum beispiel also das hier ist eine datei die keine endung
hat ja sagst du mal file ok das hat jetzt ne endung aber es würde auch ohne endung funktionieren
dann erkennt er nämlich aha das ist jason data ich zeig dir jetzt mal also dass das
auch ohne endung funktioniert hier blub heißt die datei jetzt einfach nur file blub jason
data das repo kann ich wieder löschen dass das funktioniert und woran machen die das
fest richtig die machen das an so magic magic bytes am anfang der datei fest und das heißt
aber an der stelle noch nicht dass klar ist mit was wie wo was ausgeführt wird das ist
ein bisschen unterschiedlich je nach desktop environment wenn man das genau wissen will
kann man gucken ne xdg ob so mit was das öffnen würde ne boah weiß ich aus dem kopf jetzt
nicht wie das wieder scheiß funktioniert wie funktioniert das query query kein plan
alter kein plan query jason so ich hab keinen plan wie man das abwagt ja zumindest gibt
seine tabelle im hintergrund ähnlich wie unter windows wo die erkannten file typen dann anwendung
zu geordnet werden aber das ursprüngliche dies ursprüngliche erkennen passiert nicht
anhand von endung sondern anhand von magic magic bytes in den dateien drinnen support
der mitarbeiter minder server netzwerk infrastruktur fortigen okay das heißt du machst eigentlich
mehr oder weniger alles office ran 65 wird ja immer schlimmer aber wenn es dir spaß
macht mein nur weil es mir nicht gefällt heißt ja nicht dass es dir nicht gefallen
muss ein support ist meistens nicht gut bezahlt das muss man auch ehrlich sagen gerade gerade
so so endlich end user support ist meistens nicht gut bezahlt und der rest ist halt immer
noch die frage wie tief gehen und gefragt das ist maxverkommen rastprogramm wir haben
sogar schon mal ein bisschen rast gemacht vereinzelt über die letzten jahre über großartig
rast habe ich keinen bock drauf sage ich ganz ehrlich ich habe als rast recht neu war mir
das zwei drei wochen recht intensiv angeguckt sogar schon so weit dass mein hirn automatisch
immer borough jacker gemacht hat aber ich muss sagen für alltagsprojekte taugt mir
rast einfach nix ich sag nicht dass man keine alltagsprojekte in rast machen kann kann
man sieht man zu hunderten auf github wo sachen placing die fast written in rast und das fünfte
tool in in dieser richtung aber jetzt noch mal written in rast und es kommt auch ganz
coole ideen bei raus was was ich bin trotzdem der meinung dass für alltags anwendung rast
eigentlich nicht die sinnigste sprache ist also das sind ja anwendung wo es weder auf
jetzt ultra mega krass performance ankommt weil ich mein guck mal wenn ich jetzt ls
nach in dem verzeichnis ob das jetzt ob das jetzt vier millisekunden oder acht millisekunden
brauche ich glaube das ist jetzt nicht so das coole problem und was ist einfach anstrengend
zu programmieren ich glaube dass das umschreibt am besten anstrengend und ich finde auch keine
schöne sprache von der sonntags her habe ich ja gerade schon oder was meinst du ledus
file manager mit den file extensions habe ich ja gerade schon erzählt achso moment was
was vm vm nicht fm ich habe das hier ich meine das hier was ich hier so habe guck mal ich
habe hier eine software am laufenden sich vor immer workstation da gibt es mehrere da
gibt es vor immer player da ist kostenlos es gibt virtual box ich habe vor immer workstation
kostet auch nur ein apple und ein key für vor immer workstation bei einem key shop und
damit kannst du quasi unter deinem laufenden windows noch einen zweiten virtuellen rechner
anlegen wo du da lilux betreiben kannst und das ist ausgesprochen schnell also cpu technisch
merkt man quasi kaum den unterschied zwischen host und vm also auch in benchmarks wir haben
es letztens erst gemacht das ist kaum ein unterschied und das obwohl vor immer workstation
ein bisschen probleme hat mit meiner cpu architektur mit den efficiency course und den performance
course und sowas immer optimal scheduled alles oder auch nicht optimal schedule wird
von windows alles und selbst da es war kaum ein unterschied zwischen vm und host zu sehen
ja und wenn man das auf dem zweiten desktop im fullscreen hat das eigentlich super geschichte
kannst du lilux und windows gleichzeitig verwenden du kannst da drin jetzt nicht unbedingt 3d
entwicklung machen oder sowas wenn auch wenn 3d sachen teilweise ganz gut laufen aber dafür
ist es nicht da
habe ich deine frage übersprungen weiß ich nicht sehen wir gleich oder kommt die noch
oder war die war die schon hier oben ein online bewerbungstest musstest du aktuell nicht
machen oder hast du in der vergangenheit schon mal bei allen anderen machen müssen einen
online bewerbungstest nö musste ich noch nie machen du meinst so eine fortselektion
an leuten nee das muss schon nie machen ich weiß dass das aber mittlerweile wohl recht
dem mode ist es ist auch sinnvoll ehrlich gesagt ja wenn es eine stelle ist wo irgendwie
so eine so eine personal suchvermittlungs wie auch immer firma beauftragt wurde die müssen
ja erst mal das filtern also wenn die dann 30 kandidaten haben und das dann runter zu
filtern auf 67 ist es ja schon sinnvoll das online zu machen wobei man halt auch in der
aktuellen zeit sich fragen muss gibt es überhaupt noch stellen in der it wo sich 30 leute drauf
bewerben und das stimmt wohl du meinst den den zwischen den zwischen ablagen champ ich
habe ein programm was meine zwischen der plage monitort hier guck da plus das zählt noch
nicht wie oft ich wie oft ich die gleichen sachen copy pasted habe jammel mag ich auch
nicht mal kubane das kommt ja nicht großartig dran rum gut es gibt ein paar andere möglichkeiten
aber die fort konfig sprache für kubane das ist halt nun mal jammel nachdem allerdings
jedes jason auch gültiges jammel ist könnte man auch seine sachen in jason basteln allerdings
gibt es halt jammel konstrukte die sich in jason nicht abbilden lassen aber trotzdem
ist jedes gültige jason auch automatisch gültiges jammel macht aber keiner ja kubane das konfig
wird in jammel gebastelt oder aber man benutzt irgendwelche scripting tools um das zu erstellen
gibt ja sogar leute die benutzen terraform weil ich ganz ehrlich da bisher noch nicht
so den großen vorteil drinne gesehen hab seine kubanetes konfig in hcl zu terraform sprache
zu schreiben anstatt in native kubanetes konfig warum auch immer man das machen sollte vielleicht
habt ihr eine idee ich weiß nicht genau also bis jetzt bin ich da noch nicht auf irgendwie
eine gute idee gekommen warum man das machen sollte das einzige wo ich mir das vorstellen
kann dass es sinn macht ist so für initial den cluster anlegen oder initialen node professionieren
und vielleicht die die die die die initiale konfig für den cluster mitgeben aber aber
großartige kubanetes cluster verwaltung über terraform wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich nicht
wo da der sinn sein soll state management bei terraform das stimmt wohl hast du zum
teil mit kubanetes manifest auch aber wenn du es über agor cd machst so wie wir es
gestern im stream gemacht haben da hast du das auch ja das kenne ich tragster cd k8s
oder cd kates finde ich eigentlich ganz nice das kannst du nicht nur in go machen das kannst
auch in java python go und typescript glaube ich machen dort nett war mal angedacht gibt's
leider nicht mit polumi hatte den gleichen vornachteil in dem fall wie terraform also
ich sehe den sinn ich da drinnen anstatt native kubanetes konfig zu machen das irgendwie
gewappt in terraform für initiale infrastruktur professionieren und so eine initiale konfig
vielleicht mitgeben ja aber seine hauptsächlich cluster konfig in terraform habe ich noch
nicht den sinn drinnen gesehen vielleicht gibt's ja auch vielleicht gibt's ja irgendeinen
den ich den ich noch nicht erkannt habe aber jammel ist abfakt das stimmt schon
du wirst den key shop finden der vm workstation sachen verkauft so schwierig ist das nicht
wenn du keinen key shop finden wahrscheinlich findest du auch irgendwo keys aber ich werde
hier keiner zeigen das habe ich schon mal gehört
das habe ich schon mal gehört aber keine ahnung genau was es ist und was man damit
macht wie ist deine aktuelle job bezeichnung also ab dritten vierten bin ich senior linux
engineer was ich aktuell bin habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich kann es ab dritten
vierten sagen weil es die stelle ist worauf ich mich beworben ob ich dann intern auch
diese bezeichnung habe kein schimmer ist mir auch egal was hältst du von firmen die ein
gut gepflegtes github profil für eine junior stelle erfordern erfordern können sie erst
mal viel wenn der tag lang ist wenn das google microsoft und instagram sind die können sich
das natürlich auch erlauben viele leute auszufiltern ich bin es nicht verkehrt ich finde es nicht
verkehrt zumindest zu sagen uns ist alles andere egal wenn du kein gut gepflegtes github
profil hast dann wollen wir nicht schon mal das ist natürlich doof gerade in anbetracht
der tatsache dass es schwierig ist leute zu finden aber in der stellenanzeige hin hin
zu schreiben irgendwie so bevorzugt oder weiß ich wie man das rechtlich korrekt in stellenanzeigen
formulieren kann oder so nach dem motto github profil link in der bewerbung gerne gesehen
oder sowas finde ich das vollkommen legitim weil github bzw github profil sagt halt relativ
viel über einen entwickler aus gerade wenn das wenn es wenn es eine junior entwickler
ist das sagt ja schon viel drüber aus du kannst dir angucken wie bauen die ihre projekte
so auf kann man kann es auch mal einen reingucken lassen wie sieht das aus bearbeitet er vielleicht
irgendwie wie bearbeitete issues falls es da welche gibt wieviel projekte hat er gemacht
wie aktiv ist er so wie sehen seine github mit aus kannst relativ viel drin erkennen ich
meine es ist es ist aussage kräftiger als das aussage kräftiger als wenn du einfach
nur sagst du bist der geilste ich finde es nicht ich finde es nicht verkehrt wenn man
wenn man ein bisschen auf das github profil guckt wenn man jetzt sagt oh ja uns ist alles
andere egal muss sein pflicht da muss man sich fragen können die sich das erlauben aber
es ist sinnvoll es ist schon sinnvoll zu sagen ist gerne gesehen ja
dann sind sie selber daran schuld wenn sie keine leute finden das habe ich auch schon
oft gehört dass leute bei uns jetzt ja sich beworben haben und haben dann gar keine antwort
bekommen beziehungsweise total spät die haben natürlich dann auch gesucht hier mal geht
mir am arsch vorbei also es ist mir egal ich habe schon mitgekriegt dass es teilweise
ewig gedauert hat bei uns aber uns wundert mich nichts mehr wie gesagt mein zeugnis
dauert ja auch schon wieder ewig melanox dankeschön für die 10 gigabit karte wird
die tier 1 für den sub poggers husa dankeschön fünf monate subscription aber das das ist
halt die sache die können sich nicht leisten denken aber sie können sich leisten und dann
heulen sie rum dass sie keine keine mitarbeiter finden du musst es schon irgendwie ansprechend
handeln für die leute es guckt mal es gibt auch drei sachen was man machen kann realistisch
betrachtet wenn man keine wenn man keine mitarbeiter finden gibt es drei sachen die man machen
kann das erste ist man kann seine ansprüche runterschrauben so nach dem motto alles was
wir in anforderungen haben halbieren wir mal und gucken ob wir dann was finden so was in
der richtung ganz die ansprüche runterschrauben du kannst einfach so krasse gehälter bieten
dass alle zu dir wollen das ist die zweite möglichkeit oder du kannst dich selbst attraktiv
machen also sprich vielleicht gibt es ja vorteile in der firma die die leute nicht wissen und
das kann man ja dann dementsprechend erwähnen ja dass so eine kantine im haus hast dass
du ein firmenhandy bekommst was auch für private nutzung erlaubt ist dass du einen
ergonomischen schreibtisch hast mit höhenverschärf ich mein hey man muss es ja nicht so schreiben
ich das jetzt gesagt hat man kann es ja schön verpacken aber nicht so 0815 weil stellenanzeigen
sind viel zu langweilig so immer alles 0815 gleich und dann immer so dieses haben wir
ihr interesse geweckt dann freuen wir uns jetzt über ihre aussage kräftige bewerbung
an x y z at meine firma punkt e das ist so dieser also da schreibt chat gpt sicherlich
bessere stellenanzeigen ich glaube unsere personalabteilung generell personalabteilung
könnten mit chat gpt bessere individuellere schönere stellenanzeigen erstellen als das
was sie aktuell selbst da raushauen ja und realistisch betrachtet ist es eine kombination
aus diesen drei dingern ja du musst die firma selbst attraktiver machen wenn der name nicht
schon so groß ist dass jeder zu ihm will da gibt es nicht so viele in deutschland wo
das der fall ist es sind nicht nur die üblichen verdächtigen es ist jetzt nicht nur microsoft
facebook ja wir haben wir haben was weiß ich in münchen haben wir noch nvd ob die noch
da sind wir haben nvd ja wir haben ein paar firma hersteller wir haben ein paar auto hersteller
es gibt ja durchaus leute durchaus unternehmen wo die leute auch noch freiwillig anklopft
und sagen wollt ihr nicht aber das ist halt bei vielen nicht so dass der name für sich
da alleine schon steht und die müssen sich halt in irgendeiner art und weise attraktiv
machen das schaffen sie nicht und wenn du eine kombination machst außer dein unternehmen
attraktiv zu präsentieren ordentliches gehalt bezahlst und deine ansprüche vielleicht ein
bisschen runterschraubs dann findest du auch leute zumal du ja auch so dann mitarbeiter
potenzielle mitarbeiter ansprechen kannst die gar nicht also das ist ja auch was ich
meine mit die firma attraktiv man du musst du kannst als firma heute nicht unbedingt
warten dass die leute immer zu dir kommen und ich meine nicht dass sie zu irgendwelchen
personalverschacherungs typen da rennen sollen und sich leute verkaufen lassen sollen für
300.000 euro im jahr oder so ne aber du kannst ja heutzutage schon auch leute also versuchen
leute anzusprechen die aktuellen job haben weil es ist ja bekannt dass viele leute die
eine festen festen vertrag haben eine feste anstelle festen job haben also kein also unbefristet
arbeitsvertrag haben nicht glücklich sind in der aktuellen firma und wenn du es schaffst
quasi dass diese leute anzusprechen hast du dir schon mal einen ganz großen weiteren
pool erschlossen die potenziell für dich in frage kommen aber dann musst du dich halt
auf den auf den richtigen plattform attraktiv machen als firma deine vorteile entsprechend
verkaufen und unterm strich selbstverständlich auch deine eigenen ansprüche irgendwie im
zaum halten und ein ordentliches gehalt bieten und vorteile bieten weil nur von der beteuerung
wir sind viel besser das glaubt ihr glaubt halt auch keiner mehr das sagt ja jeder jede
firma sagt wir sind die geilsten in jeder wo ich bisher gewesen bin die haben erzählt
intern wir sind die geilsten und haben sich selbst abgefeiert jede das ist normal das
machen die alle das kannst du nicht glauben wenn die sowas erzählen
welchen tiling window manager das ist die drei gibt es gibt es sowas wie x tg x tg window
session type ja ja natürlich ganz sicher ganz sicher
was sind deine aufgaben da habe ich schon video zu gemacht muss man bei mir offen ich
habe mehrere videos dazu gemacht ja das habe ich dazu gemacht zum gehalt sonst das ist
der watt channel ich habe mich schon gewundert wo kommt das video her hier laden ja manche
watts rauf zählt euch das war vor wie ods der distro der discord bot ist jetzt erst
am start nicht schlecht das finde ich auch so ja also zeugnisse finde ich ist vollkommen
okay zertifikate wenn ich arbeitgeber wäre würde ich wahrscheinlich auf zertifikate
nicht so viel nicht so viel geben was ich witzig finde so mein beispiel oder ich finde
ein negativ negativ beispiel für zertifikate ist wenn ihr mal in das kubernetes subreddit
rein guckt ganz viele leute machen dort den frag mich nicht certified kubernetes admin
ich habe keine ahnung wie dieses zertifikat heißt aus dem kopf dieses einstiegs vielleicht
weiß es jemand von euch wenn jemand weiß schreibt zu ein chat wie dieses einstiegs
kubernetes zertifikat heißt wo die da total drauf stehen gerade zumindest du hast leute
die haben mir kubernetes zertifikat haben aber noch nie einen richtigen cluster der
benutzt wird aufgesetzt und administriert wo auch wirklich was drin läuft und was ich
mir denke ja zertifikate schön und gut an diesem zertifikat erkennst du aber genau
eine sache dass er dass er jammel sonntags auswendig gelernt hat und also die basic kommandos
kennt ob dir das dann so viel weiter bringt für deinen betrieb also quasi in den kubernetes
zertifikat aber null stunden erfahrung im kubernetes betrieb ich weiß nicht ob das
dann so geil ist das zertifikat für dich ist das in einnahmequelle für hersteller
gerade im netzwerkequipmentbereich oder so ist es im appliance anbieterbereich ist es
ja so in so ein selbstversorgendes ökosystem mit schulung und zertifizierung und und der
ganze grabenfall fällt ja dann auch meistens wieder nach zwei drei jahren da muss den scheiß
wieder auffrischen und machen ist der arbeitsmarkt immer noch gut trotz der aktuellen wirtschaftlichen
lage also wenn du meinst wie die möglichkeit ist als it experte nenne ich jetzt mal an
job zu bekommen dann ist er nach wie vor so gut wie noch nie zuvor also wenn du und wenn
du einen job haben willst wo du ordentlich bezahlt wirst ist es auch aktuell so gut wie
noch nie zuvor die reißen sich alle die die die lecken sich alle so die wie nennt man
das so ein doofes sprichwort dafür die lecken sich also die finger danach so dass die leute
zu ihnen kommen was haltet ihr von kursen der vrs nix also alles was ich davon bisher
mitbekommen habe ist nicht so der burner zur vrs kannst du kannst du meine mutter schicken
und internetkurs machen oder lassen oder sowas aber der rest weiß nicht benutzt du
einen passwort manager ja mache ich ich benutze kivor jetzt habe ich alles jetzt habe ich
alles durcheinander geschmissen key vault alter ich benutze nutze key pass kivor gibt
es bestimmt auch aber ich verwende kivor nicht ich habe ein bisschen zum rumbasteln
noch mit worden wollte worden jetzt habe ich es am start ein bisschen zum rumprobieren
ist immer gut sich alternativen anzugucken aber mein main productive passwort safe quasi
ist key pass und für kubernetes zumindest lokal um externe secrets und sowas auszuprobieren
für von der config nutze ich wald allerdings in a single instant installation wald und produktiv
benutze ich aktuell noch den wie heißt das ding in asia bei google heißt google secret
secret manager bei asia ich glaube hier wald hier wald ja ach deswegen bin ich auf kivor
wald gekommen wegen escher freund bei uns hat es drei jahre gedauert drei senior ledigungen
posten zu besetzen eigentlich hätten wir gerne jemand gehabt der auch deutsch spricht ja
so ist es halt aktuell
das das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben das probieren das ist nicht wirklich stream thema
aber nur dass ich nicht vergesse jet gpt stellenanzeige generieren das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
ob da ob da was cooles bei rauskommt wie lange ist deine kündigungszeit bei der neuen firma
ist sie länger als die gesetzliche weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht wie lange die in der neuen
firma ist in der alten firma ist sie deutlich länger als die gesetzliche also als die diese
mindeste dies länger bei der aktuellen firma sind es drei monate zum ende vom quartal das
bedeutet wenn ich heute ok heute geht es noch wenn ich am ersten april kündigen würde
oder am dritten april irgendjemand kündigt am dritten april dann muss er den kompletten
april noch da bleiben den kompletten mai den kompletten juni den kompletten julie und
dann kann er erst abhauen ab august kann er dann weg so rum das ist das ist also wenn
du pech hast ist es fast ein halbes ja dadurch das stimmt wohl viele haben schlicht und greifend
eine beschissene abstimmung zwischen dem team was die stelle braucht zwischen der abteilung
die stelle braucht und der personalabteilung und denen die die stellenanzeige letztendlich
schalten anders kann ich mir manche sachen nicht erklären ich habe letztens auf twitter
aber zeigt das war eine richtig miese stellenanzeige gelesen und zwar ist nicht so lange her finde
ich glaube ich hier relativ schnell ich habe darauf geantwortet ja guck mal hat mich auch
irgend einer erwähnt hier also guck mal stellenanzeige hat sie gepostet das tätigkeit fels umfasst
folgende aufgaben system und netzwerk administrat oder windows rechner systeme klientinstallation
fehlerbehebung störungsberatung übernahme von bereitschaftsaufgaben im hard und software
bereich des laufenden produktionsbetriebes unterstützung und beratung der endanwender
in atti fragen allgemeine büro tätigkeiten neben diesen tätigkeiten ist die vollständige
mitarbeit in der finanz was ist das fake oder ist das wirklich so beschissen man also also
wer sowas geschrieben hat den musst du doch rausschmeißen eigentlich du kannst doch niemand
wirklich geld dafür bezahlen dass er so eine stellenanzeige erstellt das sind vorneweg
vier positionen in einem jahr oder auch so zu unzusammenhängendes zeug ich mein system
und netzwerkadministration der windows rechner system je nachdem wie komplex das ist und
was ist ist das schon ein job für sich klientinstallation hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht gehört
dazu aber vielleicht haben die noch irgendwas anderes als windows fehlerbehebung störungen
beseit das ist ja durchaus in ordnung so was was das jetzt auch immer genau bedeuten soll
bis du dann am fließband oder in der fabrik wenn grad kein windows rechner zu installieren
ist endanwender ist schon mal richtig abfragt allgemeine büro tätigkeiten was ist das dann
kommt dann der chef zu dir und sagt drückt mir mal excel aus oder wie und das andere
in der finanzbranche ganz ich will mal gucken von welchem arbeitgeber das ist neben diesen
tätigkeiten ist die vollständige ok das reicht wahrscheinlich schon hier haben was
gefunden simon fleisch will das haben der simon fleisch was ist das für ein lahn system
administrator kaufmännische angestellte was ist das für eine kombination mann system
administrator kaufmännische angestellter it system administrator ok hey hey die ihk freut
sich ich glaube die ihk ist die einzige die sich da freut weil laut der ihk ist da ist
der erfahr informatik ja auch ein halber kaufmann gehalt anzeigen ja das ist das ist
blödsinn dass das funkt dass das ist das ist tibet nein das ist das ist tibet guck
mal die haben auch hier was was ausgeschrieben noch job und kehre mit ihnen auf wachstumskurs
ja da gibt es keine gar als simon fleisch ist ein expandierendes unternehmen mit langjähriger
familien für eine lebensmittelbranche das ok werden sich auch mal definitiv keine veganer
bewerben dabei dass sowohl direkt über unser kerngeschäft beinhaltet schlachtung und zerlegung
von schwein sowie die herstellung vielleicht ja da hast natürlich als als admin besonders
bock in der schlachthalle rechner zu administrieren und sowas mit hauptsitz mehr als das ist das
ist so gut das ist wir das ist komplett ok anforderungen kundenkenntnisse systembetreuung
ist ist thema administration systemverwaltung ok bitte mehr synonyme noch für systemadministration
was haben wir denn sonst noch ja system fällt euch noch irgendwas ein serveradministration
noch serververwaltung das ist alles das gleiche system pflege genau system weiterentwicklung
oder sowas system erweiterte kenntnisse klient server technik alles klar hardware installation
software installation tabellen kalkulation in excel microsoft office textverarbeitung
büro minus wir bieten haben was hä was wer hat das denn zusammen copy pasted
jetzt ist das arbeitsamt am start was ist das chat gpt stellenanzeige incoming zaff ergänzende
was da ist das nicht mehr drin haben die sich vielleicht haben die sich vielleicht
hilfe geholt beim arbeitsamt wie man eine stellenanzeige schreibt und das ist noch die
email signatur von dem von dem typ vom arbeitsamt also wenn das arbeitsamt so eine stellenanzeige
schreibt dann ist ja kein wunder was dass sie da nur die fähigsten der fähigen haben
als pdf gucken uns die stellenanzeigen an ok das pdf sieht noch am besten aus wenn sie
sich in diesem profil wiederfinden nicht gibt es irgendjemand der sich in diesem profil
wiederfindet sowie ihre gehalsvorstellung natürlich ihr macht ja ihr versucht ja noch
nicht mal die leute von euch zu überzeugen also da kannst du echt nur mit dem kopf schütteln
oder neben diesen tätigkeit was ist so bescheuert was gibt es denn immer den eigentlich gibt
es dann irgendwie so einmal im monat grillteller umsonst oder die haben noch irgendwelche anderen
burner die man keinen plan was da abgeht bei denen unbegreiflich und dann und dann beschweren
sie sich dass sie keine leute finden speichers ab fürs video hast eigentlich hast eigentlich
recht ich habe schon wieder vergessen wo ich so offen hatte moment moment das muss
ich anders machen safe machen wir mal stellenanzeigen moment one drive was nein nein desktop so
ok danke für den sub vielleicht nicht vielleicht nicht die beste wortwahl
ja das kenne ich das funktioniert in der vm leider nicht es gibt viel zu wenig medels
in der it wir haben bei uns aktuell also da wo ich da wo ich aktuell arbeite haben wir
also bei uns im team gar keine nicht mehr wir hatten mal eine datenbankadministratorin
im anderen team auch keine im anderen team auch keine wir haben eine cobalt entwicklerin
und wir haben noch eine die java anwendung die pleut das sind die einzigen drei medels
in der it bei uns so in der ecke mit denen ich ab und zu mal dort was zu tun habe sondern
mehr haben wir nicht also wenn es danach geht haben wir eine frauenquote von kein 2 prozent
oder so ja front also macbook abentwicklung da haben wir tatsächlich ein paar aber das
ist komplett komplett andere andere so ressort quasi
und ich muss jetzt pennen
würdest du sagen dass der arbeitsmarkt für berufeinsteiger umschüler auch gut aussieht
ja es sieht generell im it sektor gut aus du hast in deiner verkürzten ausbildung nur
sehr wenig gelernt praxis und theorie viele stellen an seinen vier jahre entwickler haben
für meine kenntnisse viel zu hohe anforderungen ja da darfst du dich nicht gar so sehr davon
verunsichern lassen die schreiben da auch teilweise total übertriebenes zeug rein die
schreiben dann 15 punkte rein sind schon froh wenn sie einen finden der vier davon erfüllt
also teilweise schießen sie da maßlos über das ziel hinaus es spricht nichts dagegen
es trotzdem mal zu probieren wenn das so im groben und ganzen so übereinstimmt mit deinen
sachen außerdem hält dich ja auch keiner davon ab dich privat noch damit zu beschäftigen
trotz deiner verkürzten ausbildung dass er noch ein paar dinger lernt sie dich persönlich
interessieren weil umso besser du nicht oder ich muss ich anders sagen dinger die dich
interessieren den lernst du relativ schnell und ist ist auch nicht so viel arbeit sich
damit zu beschäftigen weil es da dinger sind die dich persönlich interessieren und dadurch
steigt wiederum die chance beruflich auch in diesem bereich zu arbeiten von dinger die
dich interessieren weil du hast ja schon plan davon
wie alt ist die cobalt developerin dürfte ein bisschen jünger sein als ich also ich
würde sagen die dürfte 34 35 oder so sein so genau weiß ich das auch nicht weiß nur
dass wir eine haben aber wie alt ist kann ich euch nicht sagen chat so ungefähr 35
oder so die stellenanzeigen würde ich nicht so genau nehmen ich kenne das ich kenne das
dort wo ich aktuell arbeite die haben die haben eine stellenanzeige mit rausgehauen
für einen support mit arbeiter also wo es wirklich darum ging telefonate anzunehmen
nicht endkundensupport schon intern aber wo es darum ging telefonate anzunehmen hier
hilfe mein system ist kaputt mach doch mal ein ticket auf was sie da reingeschrieben
haben linux kenntnisse windows kenntnisse vmware kenntnisse zappix azure cloud prometheus
monitoring das waren irgendwie 15 punkte wo ich mit der bereitschaft zur schichtarbeit
nacht einsetze wo man sich dann so gedacht hat alter wenn ihr jemand ernsthaft findet
denn diese 15 punkte erfüllt und dann noch einen bock hat auf nacht einsetze dann will
der garantiert nicht für das gehalt bei euch anfangen richtiges ist ja blödsinn was da
teilweise in stellenanzeigen verzapft wird so ja die ist nicht so alt für also in cobalt
entwicklern ist die ist die noch mit 35 ja noch ganz ganz jung die ist cobalt entwicklerin
geworden das weiß ich weil die war bei mir in der berufsschule die ist cobalt entwicklerin
geworden genau aus dem grund weil cobalt entwickler aussteigen und hat sich gedacht
das ist eine gute gute job gute karrieremöglichkeit cobalt entwickler zu werden cobalt entwicklerin
zu werden also ich weiß nicht ob das für mich das richtige gewesen wäre aber geld
bzw jobs wirst du wahrscheinlich auch in nächster zeit noch finden und es gibt halt nicht so
viele
welchen schulabschluss hast du ich habe den real schulabschluss gemacht irgendwann 99
oder so und der war noch nicht mal sonderlich gut
also da sieht man das ist alles kein kein hindernis wenn man ein bisschen planen hat
von dem was man macht
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das ist eine andere
versucht halt abzuschleppen ist vielleicht jetzt auch ein bisschen zu ein bisschen zu
übertrieben soweit ist es ja nicht gekommen weil ich es nicht gecheckt habe
nein nein nein nein das ist jemand ganz was anderes die mich versucht hat abzuschleppen
wenn man das denn so nennen kann das war in der in beim pro als ich noch beim provider
gearbeitet habe wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe
da war das das ist nicht beim und die cobalt entwicklerin ist ja bei meinem aktuellen arbeitgeber
die wir haben
wie gesagt mit der habe ich auch nicht wirklich was zu tun ich weiß nur dass es sie gibt ja
weil die bei mir auch in der berufsschule war und dass sie halt cobalt entwicklerin
geworden ist weil das nicht viele gibt und geld bringt
der chat wieder mann
was meinst du das ist wichtig und nö ist nicht wichtig kommt darauf an was ich wie
du so veranlagt bist ja ob du auch gerne viele theoretische hintergrund sachen lernen möchtest
letztendlich ist es nicht so wild also du kannst auch einen gut bezahlten job finden ohne studiert
zu haben
im durchschnitt denke ich muss man schon erwähnen dass jemand der studiert hat im durchschnitt
wohlgemerkt im durchschnitt nicht im 1 2 im durchschnitt mehr verdient das heißt jetzt
aber nichts wirklich individuell für dich natürlich potenziell im durchschnitt ist
das so es heißt aber nicht guck mal ich meine ich finde es auch ganz gut was ich was ich
da an job habe jetzt auch von bezahlung und so was also insofern muss ich zwangsläufig
studiert haben und dass man zu wenig in der ausbildung lernt das kann man mit dem studium
eh nicht vergleichen weil der ansatz ein ganz anderer ist was man lernt und es ist ja schon
zwischen den ausbildungen selbst überhaupt nicht vergleichbar also du hast die eine
ausbildung und die andere ausbildung nebeneinander also wenn du quasi zwei leute aus der gleichen
berufsschulklasse nimmst können die ausbildung total unterschiedlich sein oder auch die
einen richtig guten die anderen richtig beschissen kann alles ein kann sich vergleichen das
heißt du wirst so und so ich privat mit den themen die dich interessieren beschäftigen
müssen so dass du plan hast und dann geht das auch
da würde ich nicht so viel rein interpretieren was man irgendwo liest letztendlich lernt
man überall nicht genug im informatikstudium lernt man die bussiness enterprise welt nicht
kennen und ist dann vielleicht geschockt danach wie unscientific es in im bussiness tagtäglich
zu geht und umgedreht lernt man vielleicht je nach ausbildung auch nicht alles was man
braucht insofern du kannst mit beidem guten job kriegen wenn du halt was kannst beziehungsweise
halt auch vor allem ein bisschen was kannst was gefragt ist mein exchef hat einen hauptschul
abschluss und architekt jetzt ja warum nicht das ist nicht so wirklich groß relevant mehr
höchstens höchstens du gehst zu irgendwelchen behörden wo die vielleicht noch ein bisschen
bisschen boomer haft unterwegs sind und sagen ohne dass du studiert hast geht gar nix aber
selbst da merken die ja die finden keine leute da können sich das nicht mehr so wirklich
erlauben korrekt sagt du guckst immer wubblos auf twitch instant arbeitsvertrag
leute ich hab meine zweifel ob so diese sachen mit lerntüb ob es das wirklich gibt es gibt
sicherlich die ein oder anderen bevorzugten mittel wie jemand was lernt aber so dieses
ich lerne besser praktisch eher theoretisch ich glaube die bei den meisten ist es relativ
ähnlich du kommst weder mit reiner theorie weiter noch mit reiner praxis du musst sachen
praktisch machen um halt auch erstmal fehler selbst zu erleben wenn was nicht wenn was
nicht richtig funktioniert und dann nach der lösung suchen also du brauchst erstmal du
machst praktisch was du hast ein fehler und dann beschäftigt du dich mit der theorie hinter
dem fehler beziehungsweise was du am besten dagegen machen kannst wo er eigentlich kommt
also es ist eigentlich immer eine kombination aus beidem man kann gar nicht das eine oder
das andere machen du weißt meistens vorher schon wie es geht es ist unterschied selbst
wenn du die sündtags quasi theoretisch von der programmierung du kennst die sündtags
von der programmierung wirst du trotzdem sobald sie anfängt zu verwenden auf probleme
stoßen wo du trotzdem direkt wieder nachgucken musst so nach dem motto wie war das jetzt
noch mal oder wie verbindet man jetzt diese konstrukte so dass es draus kommt was ich
haben will oder musst du wieder musst du wieder suchen musst du wieder danach gucken du hast
natürlich dann den vorteil wenn du dir vorher schon mal kurz angeguckt hast dass du vielleicht
schon weißt ok nach was muss ich jetzt suchen das ist ja jeder wichtigste skill eines eines
informatikers oder jemand der in der technik arbeitet du musst wissen nach was du suchen
musst das ist das aller aller wichtigste es gibt fast nichts wichtiges es gibt fast nichts
was ihr besser können müsst als das ihr müsst so viel plan haben von der ganzen sache dass
ihr wissen aber sie suchen müsst das ist auch ein kritikpunkt den ich an vielen zertifizierungen
habe viele zertifizierungen sind super strikt so nach dem motto während die zertifizierung
läuft wirst du überwacht du darfst nirgendswo hingucken du darfst keine offiziellen hilfe
also du darfst nicht google suchen und so was das hat mit der praxis nichts zu tun und das
dumme ist halt dann lernt man in einem in einem zertifikat wie man kubernetes jammel dateien
erstellt super brauche ich wirklich den ganzen scheiß im kopf muss ich wirklich wissen dass
es api version und immer mal hier namespace na gut da ist es relativ also muss ich muss
ich wirklich wissen dass es api version customize punkt konfig punkt achts.io slash v1 beta
eins ist muss ich das wirklich aus dem kopf wissen oder kann ich einfach nachgucken wenn
ich wenn ich schreiben muss oder copy pasten von irgendwo wo ich schon mal fehlerfrei geschrieben
habe das ist halt bla bla es ist sinnlos sind das jetzt so dinger da stehen die in zertifikaten
drauf zum beispiel weiß ich noch ich habe für urzeiten auch mal einen cc na gemacht
wie fast jeder da war das auch so du musstest du musstest jeden parameter für den für
die sysco commander auswendig kennen wo ich mir so denke warum gut bei sysco ist es mit
fragezeichen noch ganz gut gelöst aber man page gucken gibt es ja trotzdem warum macht
überhaupt keinen macht überhaupt keinen sinn ja das haben die früher in der schule auch
erzählt du wirst nicht immer das internet zur hilfe haben ja in deutschland ist das
leider so da muss man mit rechnen dass ein internetanschluss mal nicht funktioniert aber
doch hat man hat man normalerweise 2023 aber tätigkeiten sind die selben bei den aus
ja mehr oder weniger also die jobs die du am ende machst das sind genau die gleichen
ich meine wenn du jetzt irgendwie dann den master gemacht hast und danach irgendwie noch
zum frage ich zum zum doktor der informatik was dich dich promoviert hast oder wie immer
man das genau nennt falls da überhaupt eine doktor gibt kein plan dann wirst du wahrscheinlich
nicht dich hinsetzen und windows installieren den ganzen tag sondern du machst es ja mit
dem hintergrund dass du in der wissenschaft arbeiten möchtest beziehungsweise machst
es dann wahrscheinlich auch schon sonst willst du es gar nicht den weg einschlagen dann machst
du natürlich was anderes aber die meisten leute die informatik studiert haben damit
bachelor aufhören die machen exakt das gleiche wie die ausgebildeten informatiker bzw fahrinformatiker
bei uns wir haben anwendungsentwickler und wir haben sogar leute im support sitzen alles
ja also leute den bachelorabschluss haben leute in ausbildung haben leute die quer eingestiegen
sind teilweise leute die sowas vorher noch gar nicht gemacht haben bis vor ein paar jahren
ist eigentlich alles dabei nebeneinander hockt das und die verdienen auch mehr oder weniger
das gleiche was sagst du zu den neuen ihk berufen ja mal gucken weiß ich noch nicht
die machen sie komplizierter die ihk könnte sich endlich mal ihre komische vorstellung
dass fahrinformatiker halbe kaufmänner sind mal über bord werfen aber ich weiß warum das so
ist es geht nicht anders weil die ihk glaube ich ansonsten fahrinformatiker nicht ausbilden
dürfte wenn es nichts kaufmännisches ist dann wäre dann irgendjemand anderes für zuständig
machst du weiter bildung neben dem beruf permanent mache ich die guckt euch doch mal an was wir
im stream machen wir haben alles schon gemacht im stream wirklich alles also ihr wisst dass
ich nicht 100 prozent abdeckung meine sondern wir haben in so unterschiedlichen themenbereichen
schon was gebastelt hier von kubernetes bis cloud geschichten microcontroller wir haben
steckdosen geflasht elektronik sachen gebastelt windows anwendung programmiert linux anwendung
web anwendungen programmiert sogar cobalt haben wir im stream schon gemacht wir haben
alles im stream wir haben fast jedes themengebiet irgendwie mal irgendwie ansatzweise gestreift
natürlich nicht in der tiefe und auch nicht in der vielfalt aber da ist alles schon mal
irgendwie dabei gewesen ja wir haben auch schon einen körnel selbst kompiliert klar haben
wir schon gemacht kann ich mich noch daran erinnern das war das stream wo ich für meinen
empfänger im wohnzimmer für den dvb-t empfänger im wohnzimmer den körnel kompilieren musste
weil der dual tuner usb stick für dvb c nicht erkannt wurde in der in der version
ist aber schon zwei jahre her also wir haben schon wir haben schon viel gemacht und das
habe ich auch in meiner in meinen in meiner skill skillliste für die für meine bewerbung
also wie gesagt das ist nicht eins zu eins die skillliste die ich in die bewerbung geschrieben
habe aber mehr oder weniger das gleiche und das ist das ist nicht gelogen das haben wir
auch zum größten teil alles schon da ich hätte da noch viel mehr drauf schreiben
können das war aber null relevant für den job ja das haben wir mehr oder weniger alles
schon im stream gemacht also ich mache ich gucke ich gucke mir permanent was an ich bin
der abs ich bin das absolute keller kind was das angeht wenn ich nicht youtube videos mache
streame oder mmo kreisel kreine oder meine zwei stunden bewegung am tag mache sitze ich
den restlichen tag vom rechner und basteln irgendwelchen shit oder basteln meine heimautomatisierung
rum oder programmieren was oder sonst was ich mache den ganzen tag nichts anderes ja ich
bin zu alt für rust rust ist zu schnell für mein gehirn zu blazing fast
die recruiter interessiert es aus folgendem grund nicht das ist ein bisschen so weil
die da sind die so die anreize ein bisschen falsch die recruiter haben oftmals vorgaben
die kriegen gesagt von den leuten die sie beauftragen wir brauchen die und die skills
und dann suchen die halt auch danach die wissen genau die andere seite ist genauso unflexibel
selbst wenn die mit dem perfekten kandidaten um die ecke kommen würden je nachdem wie
die andere seite drauf ist haben wir da kein blog drauf also sie werden dafür bezahlen
leute zu finden die diese skills haben und ganz ehrlich die recruiter frisieren auch
extrem die jetzt auf deutsch die die bewerbungsunterlagen der einzelnen bewerber also da wird ein scheiß
reingeschrieben teilweise wir hatten schon leute wir hatten schon leuten mit irgendwie
fortgeschrittener lindungs erfahrung was hat er am ende gemacht er hat mal in ubuntu
in der vm installiert und das war es der wusste davon auch gar nix dass in seinem in seinem
in seiner skillliste und in seinem portfolio quasi lindungs experience und sowas drinne
steht wie kommt das da rein das hat seine recruiter da reingeschrieben weil er den
besser verschachern können wollte das interessiert im endeffekt schon aber an der stelle vielleicht
nicht weil die eben nicht aus aus im interesse der firma denken sondern am interesse ihres
eigenen geldbeutel und das eigene geldbeutel ist den bewerber so darstellen dass in die
firma nimmt wenn die wenn unternehmen dass das selbst machen dann würde ich hoffen dass
sie auf solche dinger gucken oder dass zumindest am vorstellungsgespräch mal zur sprache kommt
weil das ist wie du sagst dass eigentlich das wichtigste was es gibt das ist vollkommen
egal meistens ob man die technologien schon großartig kennt oder nicht man muss sich ordentlich
einarbeiten können weil selbst wenn man eine technologie kennt heißt es noch lange nicht
dass man sie so kennt wie sie dort beim zukünftigen arbeitgeber vielleicht eingesetzt wird du
kannst ja sagen wir mal du kennst dich gut mit lindungs aus das ist ein sehr breites
felt das heißt noch lange nicht dass du ahnung von dem jetzt hast instant was die damit machen
wollen bei deinem neuen arbeitgeber ja oder du hast ein bisschen was mit kubernetes gemacht
aber du kannst kubernetes auf tausend verschiedene unterschiedliche arten einsetzen und was damit
machen nur weil du das tool kennst heißt noch lange nicht dass du auch den einsatzzweck beherrscht
damit wie die sich das vorstellen also dementsprechend ist das wichtigste sich einarbeiten zu können
das ist schon voll und ganz recht
ich sehe die rust task force ist jetzt auch im chat das stimmt wohl cringe wenn ich genug
hurt laufen hat oder hört oder wie auch wenn das ausspricht ist so damit da wird reingeschrieben
was die anderen hören wollen und außerdem außerdem das geht ja gar nicht
ich habe die copypasta nicht zur hand die geht ja noch ein bisschen länger
so alles klar leute wir sehen uns morgen ich hau jetzt ab gehts pen bis denn machts gut